Speaker 1: We have some what I would consider
potentially good news coming in the Ukraine
Russia situation.
Now in this particular case, what we consider
good news really depends on one's perspective
in the entire conflict and as many of you
know, at odds with what some people believe.
Both people in my audience and other people
who comment on what's going on around the
world, I do not see Ukraine as the aggressor.
I do not see the responsibility of solving
the conflict to be Joe Biden's.
I don't see the possibility of Ukraine joining
Naito as a legitimate quote aggression on
the basis of which Vladimir Putin could massed
troops at the border, threatening aggression
and if it came to it, actually execute aggression
into Ukraine.
That's not my perspective.
I see that the aggressor massing the troops
is the aggressor, and to me, that's calling
things what they are.
Now I know many of you have emailed me and
said, Well, now, you know, promises were made
that Naito wouldn't expand, and it would know
that that that is a false notion.
And we went through that yesterday.
And in the context of calling things what
they are, there are now some statements being
made by Russian authorities, which, if true,
if true, signal that this is not going to
lead to an invasion of Ukraine, which I consider
a good thing.
CNN reporting.
Russia announced that some of its troops would
return to base after completing recent drills,
but stressed that major military exercises
would continue.
Ukraine has responded understandably skeptically,
saying will believe it when we see it.
Following the announcement, the U.S. ambassador
to NATO said the U.S. will have to verify
claims of a potential move towards de-escalation
by Russia.
Meanwhile, last ditch Western diplomatic efforts
continue, with German Chancellor Olaf Schultz
in Moscow to meet Russian President Vladimir
Putin.
Late Monday, the Kremlin told CNN Putin is
willing to negotiate, saying the Ukraine crisis
was only one part of Russia's larger security
concerns.
Now, it can't be ignored that part of the
security concerns are being claimed by Russia.
Strike me as very insincere because when you
consider the broad claim that NATO's involvement
in Ukraine is a direct threat to Russia and
signals further this, that or the other thing,
the truth is that there have been other countries
in the area, including Latvia, where there
has been no such escalation.
There has been a presence or Western presence,
and there has been no such escalation.
And so it's sort of an alleged slippery slope
without really a reason to believe that that's
going to happen.
But listen, I mean, if if it's if Putin is
genuine that he's willing to negotiate and
and back down, I think it's a good thing.
And of course, the question with Putin always
is, is this 4D chess, you know, with with
Trump, we would say, well, when he when he
drew the we're using a Sharpie on the hurricane
map or when he had that insane call with Ukraine
or when he was flashing documents down the
toilet.
You know, there was this idea it's 4D chess
with Trump.
He's got something planned and very carefully
crafted.
No, he didn't.
He was a buffoon.
There was no 4D chess being played, played.
Things were what they appeared to be.
Putin is much smarter than Trump.
It's just the reality.
And so with Putin, there is the consideration
as to is this 40 chess?
And from the beginning there was the question
of is Putin's real intention to invade or
not?
And if not, what is the underlying intention
here?
The Associated Press also reporting Russia
ready to discuss confidence building measures.
And that article reads Russian President Putin
said Tuesday Moscow is ready for talks with
the U.S. and Naito on limits for missile deployments
and military transparency in a new sign of
easing East-West tensions.
The statement came after Russia announced
it is pulling back some troops from exercises
that raised fears of a potential invasion
of Ukraine.
You know, the other thing I have a problem
with in this entire context are if you've
been watching my show for some time, you are,
I'm sure, aware that when someone like me
says, Hey, this thing, Russia's doing isn't
good.
Hey, this thing China's doing isn't good.
This thing Venezuela's doing isn't good.
There is a contingent of the left that hears
that and says, David, you imperialist bastard
looking to send troops.
I don't know why I do the Alex Jones voice,
but saying, you want the U.S. troops involved
everywhere and you want Biden to send it?
No, I don't.
That's not at all what I want.
And in fact, there's really no incentive,
as many of you know, I want stability.
I want calm, even if it's out of selfish desires
for a steady economy, a calm and tranquil
stock market, part of the insanity with three
consecutive big days of market declines, et
cetera.
Part of it has been the threat of escalation
in Ukraine, Russia.
Why?
Why would I want that?
I don't.
So not not only is it not.
And I'm speaking now, not just about myself,
but others on the left who point out, Hey,
we can agree that Putin is the one threatening
aggression here while still not wanting this
to escalate and not wanting American troops
involved in we can walk and chew gum at the
same time.
And immediately, as of right now, this might
change.
But the stock market is reacting very favorably
to what seemed to be decreased tensions
in
the region.
So